"Europe will not be made all at once,
or according to a single plan.
It will be built through concrete achievements
which first create a de facto solidarity."
Solidarity has always been at the heart
of the European community.
Seventy years ago, on May the 9th, 1950,
Robert Schuman made a revolutionary declaration.
With Europe ravaged by the Second World War,
Schuman planted the seed
from which the European community of peace
grew and blossomed.
Former enemies reached out their hands in reconciliation
and became friends.
We opened borders and tore down the walls between us.
We built the world's biggest internal market.
With the continent reunified,
the European family finally became whole again.
Against all odds, we built a unique society in Europe,
where we can live together in peace and solidarity.
Today, 70 years after the Schuman Declaration,
Europeans are confronted with the deepest crisis
since the Second World War.
Too many have lost loved ones,
are fighting for their own lives
or are afraid of losing their jobs,
their livelihoods,
their future.
Still, in the midst of today's crisis,
the European spirit of solidarity was rekindled.
Leaving borders open for critical transport
of food and medical goods,
helping EU citizens travel safely home,
supporting neighbouring countries with medical staff,
investing massive resources to find a vaccine.
In the midst of this crisis, new heroes have emerged.
They are our inspiration.
Now, we are called upon to walk in the footsteps of Schuman
to write the next chapter in our history.
It is time to re-build Europe with a new recovery plan
and a heart.
It is time for a Europe where workers
have a good job to return to after the crisis,
where companies receive a helping hand,
especially in hard hit sectors.
A Europe where we harvest the energy of sun, wind and water
to fuel our cars, homes and factories.
A Europe where we join forces and invest in research
to give citizens the healthcare they need.
It is time to help each other become stronger together.
It's time to be brave, to stand up
and build a better future.
It is time to make history again.